try to have your own sound try to invent
you know dig into yourself music only
became interesting when people stepped
over boundaries you don't want to be
stuck in just doing one thing as an
artist you got it develops I noticed if
I don't enjoy myself
the crowd is more flat as well and I
want to stress that the word passion is
probably the most important in that the
past is who you are but you cannot
change the past
hello elimination my name is Evan
Carmichael my were to believe it I
believe an entrepreneur's will solve all
of the world's major problems so the
help on your journey today we're going
to learn from legendary Dutch DJ Armin
van Buuren and by States on top tendrils
suspense
rule number one is my personal favorite
and unless you know which ones you guys
like to find and as always as you're
watching if you something that's pretty
presentation view please leave it in the
comments below through others who can be
inspired my Twitter card as well and
also when you write it down as much more
likely to stick for yourself
enjoy
look at other DJs see why their sets are
good but try to have your own sound try
to invent you know dig into yourself and
see who you are and you know kind of
bring something new to the table because
if you're just copying other DJ then
you'll just be a copy so you got to find
your own identity before you go out
there if you do what what other people
are doing out there then you're not
going to stand out I always take
deadmau5 as an example hate him or love
him but what he's done is is you can put
your finger on you know putting on a
weird Mouse head making excellent music
you know that that makes a difference
that that makes you stand out and I
think the most important thing is if you
want to be successful that you do
whatever you love you look at other
artists of course you look at other
artists I do that as well you get
inspired by other people's music but try
to make it your own and I mean think of
all these people right now sitting at
home and you're doing a concert in their
City ask yourself why would why would
these people when they're at home
they're comfortable they're warm they're
having a pizza they're having they're
watching TV why would they come out to
see you you know answer that question in
two sentences and that's your answer
right there I mean why would you go see
deadmau5 because he's a brilliant
producer - brilliant DJ and he puts on a
weird mouth set and everybody goes crazy
don't know so that that that tells you
the whole story and I think that that's
what you have to do look for look inside
yourself who do I want to be what do I
want to represent and what is what is my
what is my sound and of course we will
look at other DJ's but if you want to
add something don't copy what's already
out there but try to make things make
your sound current but make it your own
sometimes a instrumental tune it can get
in the in the charts but it won't get as
high like full focus was obviously the
first single from Mirage I consciously
made the choice to make an instrumental
track as the first single that wasn't a
commercial choice I just wanted to show
the people hey you know this is what
rocks the dancefloor and I know where I
come from but I think all music grows if
you
try to step over your boundaries you
know if you look at the history of music
whether it's Bach or Beethoven or the
Beatles and Bob Dylan or Pink Floyd they
all looked at each other and music only
became interesting when people stepped
over boundaries but you see the same
thing happening now with David Guetta
and all kinds of hip-hop artists teaming
up I think it's all it's only
interesting from music so I made the
conscious choice to make half the album
of Mirage instrumental trans students
that's where I come from that's what i
DJ that's the sound that people know me
for that's what I like tracks like or
beyond coming home Mirage and all that
sort of stuff and then the other tracks
are just a little bit experimentation
you know I like all kinds of music I
like the more housey stuff I like the
more techy stuff I like a good song so
for me Mirage is also a little bit of a
little bit of a tryout to see if people
like this new direction that I'm taking
I think I'm the first DJ that ever did a
tryout show like what I do in theaters
and was but it was incredibly inspiring
to work with such a big group of people
to travel around the world you know
normally I would just show up with a bag
of records and maybe my tour manager and
a light guy and now we travel the world
with a group of 35 people and even
though financially was the worst year
I've ever had it was creatively it was
such an inspiring thing because I
learned so much actually a my current DJ
sets we still use a time code system
that we designed for the Armin only show
so you know I learned so much that my
performances got better thanks to that
and it's just I think as an artist you
should show doo-doo to people that you
don't want to be stuck in just doing one
thing as an artist you got to develop
you have to you know get in touch with
new sounds try different things you like
only another you record with mr. probz
for example I hired an entire string
orchestra if you listen to the track the
strings that are in the track are real
so you can actually hear it because
they're not exactly on time a little bit
off but that gives it the human feel so
I was actually conducting an orchestra
you know to generate and it's great
because it I'm not I'm not a conductor
I'm not I'm not I'm not a musician in
that sense but it's great to learn I
learned so much from that experience and
I think you should show that to your
fans you know
I can't do the same thing twice even
though I have a lot of nostalgic
feelings for the past I want to keep
learning and this is something I've
invested a lot of time in music oh I've
been educating myself a lot on my iPad
following courses online and learning a
lot of new techniques new plugins new
sounds so you have to do that to stay
fresh and stay focused recently I
started touring with this Armin only
concept which we brought to Madison
Square Garden in New York and the forum
in LA and a couple of other venues I was
really exciting to do the the idea
behind the shows that I'm the only DJ
hence Armin only then we have the state
of trance which is uh basically my own
festival it's a radio show that I do
live events at the radio shows weekly
but then once a year I throw a massive
event with which five areas and that's
all broadcasted live and for free so
that's different I'm just trying to
evolve you know doing things that I like
things that make me exciting keep me
excited and you know keep focused on the
music
it's all about the end of the day what
do you want to deliver as an artist what
do you want to bring what you want to
tell and it's so I mean the thrill that
you get of an idea I mean I had the idea
of a ping-pong for example I mean
everything in dance music right now is
so serious I wanted to add a little bit
of a fun element I mean it's a little
bit of an ironic truck needed in four
hours
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
ping pong was just uh you know silly but
I didn't even want to release it
initially but it's it's so great that
with all my tracks they're all my babies
and there you see crowd going crazy to
an idea that you had in your head and
then they and they go and it's that's
that that gives the biggest kick
self-education why not instead of
watching another series that everybody's
talking about use that exact time and go
online and watch couple of these
tutorials because that's what inspires
me I learned a lot of tricks of reducing
making specific sounds you know how can
I make this pad and make it sound really
why how come eight this trance relative
how do you program that I'll kind of
make my kick sound really fat how can I
have that clap with the big reverb
behind it and reverse it and how do you
do that how do I arrange my song you'll
have enough elements to arrangement so
all these questions and a million more
you get a find answers online I promise
you as soon as you finish a couple of
these courses you're being so inspired
and the music will start writing itself
well before we start doing this we had a
massive rehearsal time and we hired the
Brava Paula information and Headlands
who flew all the artists to the
Netherlands and for three weeks we
rehearsed so every single practice
rehearse with staging we have the entire
stage there and no crowd and then we did
try out to try outs front of a live
audience
and then you need these see where where
the problems are so then we again we we
rehearse and rehearse rehearse to get it
better and better and better and then we
did the premiere show at this legal girl
man apps now we did the show for the
very first time and then you see that
show get better every time to do it
also my freestyles changing every time
so it's exciting for the crudeness they
don't hear the same music and we show so
every army only showed it I do is
different from the tractus from the
shorted and Oakland
different than detractors come ashore in
them so it makes it exciting for
everybody
and the crowd the crew feels really
relaxed because they know exactly what's
going to happen so if I select a track
in the live element my stage manager
backstage and sees it on his iPad and
sees what tracks I select and then the
next artist will be ready and the artist
knows ok whatever track he you have to
be running before he knows that he or
she need to walk on stage and one minute
40 so everything everybody prepared and
you know preparation is key and that's
what I learned from working with a
theater director you know instead of you
know the awkward feeling like sort of
pushing a microphone in a mixer and say
hey hey sing yeah go sing instead of
doing that we make sure that the artist
gets vocal coaching an artist is without
a artist gets treated well it's only
because everything is organized in a
range but it's a feeding operation I
don't feel garbage sees a DJ I don't
like that expression I feel I'm really
part of the crowd in a way I try to
enjoy the music as much as possible
because I noticed if I don't enjoy
myself the crowd is more flat as well
you know people expect me to enjoy
myself and I'm enjoying the music just
as much or even more than the crowd
because I'm really really into it and I
feel that's my assignment and I want to
stress that the word passion is probably
the most important in that you have to
really really really want something and
I think in life it's so much more easy
if you are devoted and dedicated to
something if you like your job
no not like your job love your job
you'll be 200% good at it because you're
passionate about it so ask yourself on a
daily basis it's what I'm doing right
now is it something I love because if
you don't love what you're doing you're
actually wasting your time you should
stop doing what you do he should try and
search for something else because I'm
convinced that if you don't love what
you do you're only doing at maybe at 50
or 70 percent of your of what you could
do and if you love what you do you're
really passionate about you do you love
your job or your love your
work or you love whatever you're doing
and you'll go for 200% and then you'll
see that you can really excel you go you
can reach stuff
beyond what you expected you would I
mean people always ask me like why do
you do a tower DJ Sims it's because I
love it man I want to play all this
music and then it's physically it's not
healthy to not go to the bathroom for
six seven hours and I do it because I
just don't think about going to the
bathroom I just feel the need to to
perform I like I'm in the zone I'm in
the moment I want to rock that crowd and
that's what I mean you you excel you go
beyond your human being can really
achieve it's like what obi-wan Kenobi
said you know it's if he could put your
mind to it it can accomplish anything
but you have to understand for me when
I'm in the studio I'm not thinking about
creating a hit record or creating a pop
record like you're really saying what
you want to create I'm just doing
something that comes from my heart okay
and sometimes it will please you and
sometimes it won't so one day I'll make
I'll produce a track for the gaya guys
one track one day I'll make a one three
eight the game of thrones remix and then
the next day I'll be making a downtempo
track it's good to have a plan it's good
to have a clear idea of where you want
to go but along that if you take that
path and along that road can be it can
be bumpy and sometimes the roads blocked
you have to go somewhere else you have
to take a detour I think it's really
important to look after your health I
mean really don't smoke don't drink too
much take care of your own body you know
your body is your temple it's the it's
the only thing that's with you all the
time so the past is who you are but you
cannot change the past now in my job I'm
always looking for the next gig and the
next album and the next tour so I'm
always living like two three months
ahead but I want to be more into now you
know when I'm with my family on holiday
we're having
and we're going to the beach or
something I wish I could just stop this
head you know stop the train and be in
the now for me I can say that trance is
emotional uplifting mostly instrumental
music that just touches your soul a
little bit it's very very close to
classical music you know it's about it's
about the melody more than the beat it's
more it's about that you have the flow
that you get into listening to it you
just know you know when you're in love
it's just very simple it's one of those
strange things in life you know I mean
anybody that's married can tell you this
so easy to fall into the trap of being
roommates with each other you know
so me my wife would go on dates we
totally brought back date night doing a
big show
especially when I did the army only
shows for my last album intense and now
for the upcoming album when I want to do
a new tour called embrace it's so much
energy that you see when you see these
people in front of you you get so much
love from that crowd but you always have
to pay a price somewhere so the day
after such a big performance I'm empty
man when I get up in the morning the
first thing that not good goes through
my head is not like oh how can I make a
million bucks or how can I be number one
DJ in the world that's not what goes
through my mind I get up thinking hey Mr
probz is coming over and we're doing a
track together how exciting and that's
really what moves me the motivation is
to have fun in the studio and I
understand that now it's so important to
go into the studio and have fun I find
it hard to believe that you have the
time to you know start working on an
album that you know doing collaborations
but also at the same time how do you
pick your collaborators it's it's sort
of it just happens really you meet
somebody say hey let's do a track
together you send each other a text
message or an email and then you know
you're trying to find a date you sit in
the studio together I mean honestly half
of the collaborations that I try to set
up didn't work out simply because the
artists in one - there was no time or at
other priorities one of the
collaborations I'm really proud is
actually not on embrace
it's with jean-michel Jarre synthesize a
legend for his album he approached me
and he said I wanted to attract with you
for my next album
[Music]
I remember I was a little kid looking
going through my dad's record collection
seeing these humongous covers of of
Jamia gel jars so you know the day that
I could tell my dad and I was actually
working with the legend himself was was
unbelievable so we created a track
together that I'm really proud of called
Stardust has more of my older
transy melodies my older sound and it
was so much fun to do as well so this is
what I want to show you you know in one
year working with jean-michel Jarre
working with Hardwell working with mr.
probz working with a jazz trumpet I mean
that's fun that I mean that you go into
the studio and you're like wow it's not
just you know another singer or another
you know another celebrity who wants to
work with you know it's about you go
into the studio you try and do different
things and you try different sounds and
you go out of your comfort zone a little
bit that challenges me I mean I'm so
inspired right now I could easily if you
put me in the studio right now in a year
from now I'll have another album I have
so many ideas and that's because I'm
having so much fun in the studio right
now last time I was here at old Ferry I
had an idea for this to use this from
kids who say it sounds like a like a
March like like like jay-z army coming
place coming breaks coming
the war is about the start
away
[Music]
this chart is going to be of the next
album is lagana said it's just this is a
that addition to to the actual track is
just to break like a little piece so
that's that you listen to song they're
barely doing this video
[Music]
thank you guys so much for me I mean
this beauty because Beach a balancing
act so does the same account refer that
is you want me to profound max technical
link in the description you can go and
cast your vote alpha must know which
clips residents and most of you what
left me to teach this video and
immediately apply human life for tubers
and somehow leave it down the comments
below
I'm really curious to find out what you
have to say I also want to give a quick
shout out to Lucas Alexander to just
thank you so terrifically popping my
cell theory one word and posted that
picture in advance and really really to
support made and are so glad you enjoyed
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you hopefully teach to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love
we had a ten thousand plus people in so
we saw yourself miss criminals who had a
while to Vidal said yeah how would they
I did behind the line with it
well I always the arm it only has
Christmas dinner with Armin van Buuren
so you know I also also want to show my
fans I'll never forget where I come from
right and instead of playing reworks of
the classic Oceanside you know why not
display the original vinyl you need to
inspect the original sound of the
classic very and I always felt that you
know Lionel added something special with
sound the finals have it only specialty
that transmitted because actually you're
in less inflammation than from the CD or
from a USB key because the the sound
characteristics of Lionel they cut away
the you know parts of the freight
Cleveland suspension but it just adds
something to the sound you know and yeah
it's a little gift to my fans budgets
[Music]
love it honey you know the DJ for such a
long time in my career that you know to
keep it interesting and exciting for
myself I love doing fairies so what
keeps me excited for all these years is
a coursing music to fast also you know
doing all these different shows and
trying to contain and I mean a show like
Armin only is not not just you know the
way to promote the music and whatever
but it's really also for myself to keep
it exciting and I want to wake up in the
morning thinking I'm going to go to LA
and the show during this person that for
some secret to success as a couple of
elements that are important in success
first of all is your own level of
expectation you also have to learn to be
happy with what you achieve sometimes
it's impossible in life to always
achieve exactly what you have in the
back of your head so you need to learn
also to be happy with what you achieved
even if it's only half of what you had
in mind at first I like a quote of John
Lennon life's what's happening the lifes
what's happening to you when you're busy
making other plans and that is what I
keep telling my wife as well and all a
lot of people around me you always
expect something and then something
along the way comes and then you have to
alter your path again and if you can
learn to live with that and you can be
practical like that then success is more
easy maybe it's good to have a plan but
it's also good done if you're working
really hard and you're walking up
against the door and you can't go
through that door then you know you just
find a back door it's find your way
around it and that's just the way that
life is sometimes you cannot get exactly
what you want or what you had in the
back of your mind yes it's very
important that you have to have a good
work ethic nobody gets anywhere without
hard work and you'll have good and bad
days even myself as a producer I run
into disappointments almost on a daily
basis because I try to work with artists
that on the last moment pull back their
song or you know you don't see that you
don't read that in the news but it's the
fact of the matter and I think all
artists have to deal with stuff like
that you don't get the set times you
want you don't get the billing you want
you don't get the hotel room that you
require
it's something you have to deal with and
it you know defines your character how
easy you are to deal with stuff like
that you know life is a rollercoaster
ride for everybody it has its ups and
it's downs but if everything goes well
you'll have more ups and downs and
you'll remember the ups more than you'll
remember the downs but it's the fact of
the matter that everybody no matter if
you're a big artist a successful artist
or a successful businessman everybody
works hard to get somewhere it's not
about you know how many Grammy
nominations you have or how many times
you want DJ Mag or whatever it's not
about that it's at that point you're
just trying to rock the crowd you're
trying to interact with people and it's
so beautiful I mean to feel that
connection with a crowd seeing all those
people having the best time of their
lives you're in an office during the
week and they dress up and they go out
and and you're you get to be the guy
that gets to entertain them that's that
that is that is so beautiful I mean from
all the things that I'm doing in my
career you know jet LAG's
airports waiting taxes everything from
all the things that I do in my career
that is the only thing that that I'm
still not bored with you know this is a
thrill I mean why did why are the
Rolling Stone still playing when they're
70 years old it's because you can never
get enough of that kick of the love of
the crowd I mean it's an addiction for
sure